Tung tâm sự báo khi tự thị văn Quốc gia cho biết, sự báo đến bẩy giữa sáng ngày 22 tháng 6,
á thấp dự đối trên biển đông có khả năng mạnh lên thành báo số 1.
Lúc này, tâm báo nằm trên khu vực quân đạo hoang gia, vùng gần tâm báo,
sức só mạnh cấp tâm cấp chiến, dật cấp mềm một.
Sau đó, báo số 1 tiếp tục di chuyển theo hướng tây tây bác với tốc độ mười đến 1.5 kilomét trên dự.
Đây sẽ là cơn báo đầu tiên trên biển đông và trên khu vực tây bác thái bình dương năm nay.
Chúng tâm sự báo khi tự thị văn Quốc gia cạnh báo,
á thấp dự đối sắp mạnh lên thành báo trên biển đông sẽ gây ra só mạnh,
sống lớn trên nhiều vùng biển.
Trong bố mấy tám đến bẩy mấy 2 giờ tối,
vùng biển bác biển đông và phía bác hú vực sữa biển đông và vùng biển ngoài hư từ khoảng 4.5 gần,
gió mạnh cấp sảo cấp bẩy, dật cấp chiến, biển đông,
sống cao hai đến bồn mẹt.
Tào thiền hoạt động trong các vùng biển nói trên sẽ đối mặt với viêm,
dùi gió cao trong buông, lúc sống mạnh và sống lớn.